the elements that have inverses modulo
and will be particularly important to us
and so the first question is how many of
them are there which is what Euler's
function tells us so the definition of
euler's function fee fee of M is it's
the number of integers in the remainder
interval from 0 to n minus 1 such that K
is relatively prime to n so remember
there's the notation for the remainder
interval that includes 0 and excludes n
and the another way to say relatively
prime to n is to say the GCD of K and N
is 1 so let's define that set of numbers
that were interested in G so let G C D 1
of n be those numbers that have a GCD of
1 within that is the numbers that have
inverses and the numbers that are
cancelable modulo n so what it means is
that V of n is precisely equal to the
size of GCD one event now some authors
call GCD one of N and star I didn't find
that a very informative notation and so
I'm not using it fee of n is also for
your information called euler's totient
function but we'll just stick to coil or
calling it fee or euler's faith so let's
look at an example GCD 1 of 7 the
numbers that are relatively prime to 7
are all the number all the positive
numbers less than 7 because 7 is prime
so it's the set 1 2 3 4 5 6 GCD 1 of 12
is the numbers that have no factor in
common with 12 there the numbers in
green below and the other red numbers do
have a number in common with 12 I do
have a prime in common with 12 the
pattern here is not so apparent anyway
fee of 7 is the size of GCD 1 of 7
namely the size of the set 1 through 6
which is 6 GCD 12 determines fee of 12
12 is the number of green elements
which is four okay um a simple rule for
calculating fee when fee is prime we've
already indicated namely everything
every positive number less than P is
relatively prime to pay and so fee of P
is simply P minus one let's look at a
more important example or illustrative
example namely fee of nine well okay so
there are the candidate numbers from
zero through eight and which ones are
relatively prime to nine well it's
relatively prime to nine if and only if
it's relatively prime to three now which
numbers in this interval are relatively
prime - throughout are relatively prime
to three or rather are not relatively
prime to three well it's every third
number that's divisible by three so
those are the bad ones if we subtract
the bad ones we're left with the good
ones the ones that are relatively prime
so a fee of nine is simply the set of
all the numbers - one third of nine
which is the bad one bad ones namely six
this generalizes to a power of a prime
if if K is a positive integer then V of
P to the K the reasoning is that a
number is relatively prime to the P to
the K if and only if it's relatively
prime to P P divides every peeth number
so one piece of the numbers in the
interval are bad which means that fee of
P is the good ones - one piece of P to
the K namely fee of P to the K is P to
the K minus P to the K over P which can
also be expressed in a more standard
form P to the K minus P to the power K
minus 1 and that knocks off the story of
fee when a fee to the P for powers of
primes well suppose you're dealing with
a number that's not a power of a prime
and there's one very elegant little fact
about fee that explains how to deal with
non powers of primes namely if a and B
are relatively prime then fee of a B is
simply gotten by computing fee of a
and multiplying it by fee of B this
property of fee is called multiplicative
'ti by the way it comes up a lot in
number theory a function is
multiplicative when its value at a
product of relatively prime numbers is
the product of the values at those two
relatively prime numbers so fee is
multiplicative now the proof of that one
proof is on problem set five and there's
another proof that we'll see in a couple
of weeks when we get into counting and
the inclusion exclusion principle let's
just use this fact about fee the
multiplicative fee multiplicative 'ti of
fee to see how it lets us calculate V of
an arbitrary number so in particular fee
of 12 which look complicated earlier
well 12 is 3 times 4 so that means that
V of 12 is fee of 3 times V of 4 but now
I'm in great shape because 3 is a power
of a prime namely 3 to the 1 and 4 is a
power of a prime namely 2 squared so
applying the power of prime formulas I
get that fee of 3 is 3 times 1 times 2
squared minus 2 to the 2 minus 1 which
simplifies to 4 which is the answer that
we saw before and the punchline for why
we're examining faith is Euler's theorem
which tells us how powers of numbers in
GCD 1 of n behave namely that if K is
relatively prime to n then if you raise
K to the power fee of n it's congruent
to 1 mod N and that will lead us in the
next section we will look at the proof
of euler's theorem